Speaker 1: Republicans are increasingly
demanding, suggesting that Ron DeSantis
block the extradition of Donald Trump from
Florida to New York. If indeed Donald Trump
is indicted and arrested in the state of
New York, as many of us believe he might be,
I guess although it was supposed to happen
Tuesday and then Wednesday and then it didn't
happen. Put that aside for a moment. More and
more Republicans are making the request that
DeSantis block the extradition of Trump to
New York. Can dissenters even do this? Well,
that's a good question. We'll get to that in
a moment. First, here is Florida Republican
Congressman Matt Gaetz making the case. If I were.
Speaker 2: Governor of Florida, I would not allow
any Floridian to be hauled before some Soros
backed prosecutor in some blue city over politics.
And I wouldn't make an exception to not protect
the president of the United States. Ron DeSantis
should be standing in the breach to stop any
sort of extradition of President Trump from
the state of Florida. And the fact that he's not
doing so puts every Floridian at risk who could
be the subject of a false allegation. I know Ron
DeSantis well. He's a friend, but he hasn't been
the target of false and persistent allegations
like President Trump has. And so I don't think
he really understands the nature of this fight
right now. I think that it was a bit uncouth for
him to take a jab at the former president. And
there's a role for the governor of Florida here,
I think, to stand up for our state, for the
rule of law, and to push back against the
Soros ization of the criminal justice system.
Speaker 1: So is it actually something that Ron
DeSantis can do? I will tell you in a moment,
Charlie Kirk making the exact same case about
this extradition. And everybody is on message with
the Soros stuff, you will notice it doesn't Ron.
Speaker 2: DeSantis create a sanctuary state for
a former president under political persecution.
If the left is able to create sanctuary states
for rapists and murderers, thugs and criminals.
I don't think it's too big of an ass
for Ron DeSantis to create a sanctuary
state for a former president who's being
persecuted. By a Soros funded DEA. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So it's an interesting legal question.
Can a governor block the extradition of an
indicted person from their state to the state
in which they are indicted? Can a governor do
that? Governors do have the power to block
extradition of a person who is wanted in
another state. But in very limited circumstances,
a governor may block the extradition of a person.
If the governor determines that the person's
rights would be violated in the extradition,
or if the governor believes that the request for
extradition is politically motivated or improper.
Now, that just happens to be exactly what these
right wingers are claiming. They are saying that
the the prosecution of Trump, if it happens,
is politically motivated, would be politically
motivated. However, it is not that the governor
just says, yep, it's politically motivated,
so there's no extradition. If a governor asserts
that they are blocking extradition from their
state to another for that reason, it can be
challenged in court. And ultimately it's up
to courts to determine whether extradition should
be allowed. From everything I've read right now,
there is every indication that if DeSantis
tried to block Trump's extradition from
Florida to New York on these grounds, courts
would say, You can't do it. Also worth noting,
governors cannot block extradition to another
country that falls under federal jurisdiction.
So it's a nice little pipe dream that Charlie Kirk
and Matt Gaetz have. But it is very unlikely to be
what keeps Trump out of the state of New York.
And by the way, Trump's lawyers have already
said he would surrender. Will it happen? Will
the arrest happen? That's a different question.